a little bit of an interesting addendum
with the whole disney and the don't say
gay bill thing now disney had made the
claim that they had been working behind
the scenes to try and prevent the bills
passing or to get a reward in a way that
would have been far less damaging
obviously failing at doing so now the
tampa bay times has now done reporting
an investigation basically backing that
up they were in fact working behind the
scenes they worked with some senators to
try and get amendments passed that would
have softened the damage they actually
met with the chairman of the republican
party in florida to talk about the
impact on their employees
and that's honestly a pleasant surprise
to find out is actually true i don't
retract any of the criticisms i made in
my video however because if anything i
think this just shows what a
self-inflicted wound it was for disney
to be silent publicly even as they did
this heck you could make the argument
that had they been pushing it publicly
as well maybe that additional pressure
would have been enough to actually make
a difference so while it's nice to find
out that we're actually trying to do
something i still stand by everything i
said